>> The big question that I think needs to
be answered is how can we
provide entrepreneurial education to the poorest
of the poor?
Access to education as we know it is no longer
sufficient or valid,
only access to education but education that
has no quality, does not
produce any tangible results.
Many of the world's poor have access to education
and, in fact, have
been to third, sixth, ninth grade.
That has not changed anything, so what we
need is more practical
entrepreneurial education to everybody.
In order to facilitate the resources to provide
this education we think
that education should pay for itself or could
pay for itself by
income-generating educational programs on
campus with teachers and with
students.
But we think that if we do not do something
with quality education
right now, we will not be able to overcome
the challenges that we're
facing right now.
Thank you very much.